so if you were if you were conservative
if you were a Republican right now and I
and you were in a trump guy what would
you do because I find they're in a real
bind right now because if you're a
mainstream establishment Republican I
don't think you can go into that
convention and say we're gonna steal
this thing away because we don't like it
they would it would expose such a
horrible flaw in the system and really
be undemocratic and at the same time
they're giving up their party but I
think they've already exposed that I
mean I don't believe the Republican
Party is against government at all
government is how in my lifetime they've
redistributed wealth to the top two
percent they don't dislike government
they dislike democracy and we've seen it
time and time again look at these look
at these ridiculous voter ID laws that
as soon as the Supreme Court removed the
preclearance regulations in 2013 these
voter ID laws go up all over the place
because they want as low it turnout as
possible we know they don't care about
the will of the people based on Bush v
Gore we know that they don't care about
democracy but government they're not
really against that yeah would you be
for just like a basic voter ID
registration thing just that you just
have to have some level of
identification some government-issued
identification cuz I get you on that but
I don't think you should just be able to
walk in with nothing and just sign well
if you've registered your name is on a
is on a registry when you go in to vote
right but shouldn't you have to prove
that you are that person shows up and
votes in your place you know the fact is
are you gonna say that this is a right
unless you get a photo ID and many of
these photo IDs you have to pay fees to
get so in reality that's a poll tax and
so you know a lot of folks say that
gutting the Voting Rights Act in 2013
which was done by the way the same week
they greenlit sharknado 2 like that was
just the end of our country in my total
total coincidence like you know it
doesn't just keep african-americans from
voting it was designed to keep seniors
low income people of all races and
college kids from voting
there's districts in this country where
you can vote with an NRA ID but not a
university ID and the right wing
response to that is well yeah but
foreigners can get college IDs well yes
but foreigners can't register to vote so
that's not a problem more people are
killed by televisions every year that
are then vote illegally the New York
Times did an extensive study and found
that out of over a billion votes cast
far less than 1% were fraudulently cast
there is voter registration fraud
there's not voter fraud it's designed
deliberately to make people vote less
right I would say there's got to be some
way that it can be subsidized to just
give everyone some card that proves who
they are even even even if the numbers
are incredibly low and then you register
and then you have some card that has
your picture on it and with the
government paid for it that's it get a
voter registration card every year to
your home address but you know for me
it's like this this whole thing with the
voter ID laws is just more proof of how
undemocratic the entire process is and
and I really think that what we should
be talking about is how to make it
easier to vote not harder why why do we
only vote the first Tuesday in November
well it's because we're still living by
18th century standards in an agrarian
economy we were mostly farmers and you
were planting your crops up until you
know you were harvesting up until the
end of October and then the presumption
was the first Sunday in November you'd
go to church and then Monday it would
take you one full day traveling by horse
or mule to get to the nearest polling
station and then you could vote on
Tuesday so we're being controlled by the
living habits of people who've been dead
for over a hundred years instead of
having it be like motor-voter where you
get your registration as soon as you get
your license why can't we have a holiday
to vote back that to me is the number
one one take my day off yeah we're be
able to vote online I mean we should
make it a lot easier we should be trying
everything we can do to drive up voter
enrollments to drive a voter
participation how people manage their
own democracy but since the beginning of
this country when the founding fathers
thought only land owning white men
should be allowed to vote we've always
talked the talk we haven't walked the
walk and so I'm a big fan of democracy
yeah tomate yeah democracy is good I
will I will agree with you on that one
all right so let's talk about the
Democrats a little bit I suspect but I
can't totally confirm you're a Bernie
guy right I'm a bernie guy yeah just
by policies alone but I mean no no
candidates ever gonna you know we have
these purity tests for our politicians
and no politician no lover no relative
no artist is ever gonna match your
entire checklist I mean every rocks the
car you've ever admired has released a
bad album or done something embarrassing
every great filmmaker has a plug no
politician is going to match your purity
test at all and I see the Democratic
Party which I'm not a member of I'm
independent I always have been mm-hmm
I'm not a Democrat Republicans generally
forced me to vote that way but I see the
civil war where it's like you know mom's
friends fighting with grandpa's friends
and it's so ugly I don't want to watch
Margaret Thatcher her beat-up five-ish
Finkle in a cage match this Civil War of
the left is the most depressing thing
about a generally depressant election
year and you know I have a lot of issues
with Hillary Clinton but I don't really
think that I'm ready to hand the nuclear
launch codes over to Donald Trump just
yet right so let's unpack that a little
bit because I'm fully on board that that
one of my problems with the left right
now is they have gone out of their way
to demonize Hillary to a point that
they're making it sound like she is a
neocon that she wants to build nations
and fight all these extra Wars now I get
it she did vote for Iraq she did vote
for the Iraq war she was Secretary of
State when when Benghazi happened but
Barack Obama was President Barack
Obama's president right now where we
have some troops now in Syria we have
Afghanistan thank god it's the most
disgusting thing they've got
I mean exploiting the murder of these
four people I'm pretty sure that it was
terrorists who did it but we've seen
this whole process of how can we take
these corpses and use them against
politicians we don't like first it was
Susan Rice that it was Barack Obama now
it's all Hillary Clinton's fault these
folks have never blamed the terrorists
they've never held the CIA or Petraeus
responsible for what happened there and
we're never gonna know because most
likely I mean Petraeus's mistress said
in the speech that there was a black
site prison in the basement of that
consulate so we're never gonna know the
whole stories you know for me I find
half my day is spent defending Hillary
Clinton against unfair attacks
I think blaming a woman for her
husband's infidelity yeah good luck
getting female voters with that I mean
I hear people bringing up Bill Clinton
rate 28 abroad Rick again well this has
nothing to do with policy and Bill
Clinton is not running but Donald Trump
has been accused of rape Ronald Reagan
was accused of rape Bill Clinton was
accused of rape what are we gonna do so
this goes to that purity thing that you
mentioned because it seems to me that
the far left has taken Bernie and
they've basically said Bernie's our
Jesus we love all of these ideas and at
the same time we love them so much that
we have to destroy Hillary and what I
see the problem there is is that
ultimately you could end up assuring in
president Trump absolutely because the
left will be they've demonized her to
the point that all these young people
are just not gonna vote right
yeah I'm voting for new ones I think you
know like I don't blame Ralph Nader for
George Bush becoming president I thought
it was great that Nader ran and I think
he had a right to run and I think that
he had the best policy position of any
candidate that year I do blame 90,000
idiots in Florida who knew they were in
a battleground state and voted for Nader
anyway see I'm voting for nuance mom I
like Bernie a lot on paper but the the
magic number of this campaign date is a
hundred and forty seven that's Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's age oh this year you're
voting for the Supreme Court possibly
voting for three judges on the Supreme
Court would you rather have Hillary
Clinton appoint someone who respects
women's reproductive freedoms or would
you rather have Donald Trump but a
Moroso or Gary Busey on the court right
this is what we're looking at right here
and so I think that uh what's probably
gonna wind up happening is Hillary
Clinton will get a lot of people's votes
she won't get their enthusiasm well that
seems pretty obvious I mean even the way
you're describing not that you're saying
you're supporting her but even the way
you're talking about her is sort of just
like it's like a tepid defense right
good keep saying of all my shows tepid
is the new black
you know again it's like it's like I
think that there's a lot of folks who
don't like Hillary personally or don't
like her policies and I get all of that
I will say that if she means half of
what she said on this election trail the
2016 Hillary is a much better candidate
than the 2008 Hillary I've been very
very impressed with
and I give Bernie Sanders a ton of
credit for forcing her to take these
moral positions that would actually help
the middle class and help our economy I
think Elizabeth Warren gets a lot of
credit - it's clear Secretary Clinton
has read senator Warren's book but I
have a lot of issues with Hillary and
let me tell you I I posted a couple of
jokes defending her against these sexist
attacks against her because of her
husband's infidelity which i think is
that one of the tackiest things you can
do and the amount of progressives who
came after me over it is dispiriting
because you know I don't consider Monica
Lewinsky to be a victim I think what
Bill Clinton did was wrong and
unprofessional and I think he's paid a
very deep price for it and but I don't
consider Monica Lewinsky to be a victim
and and by having that point of view
because it was a consensual relationship
between two adults by her own testimony
she pursued it and you know and I happen
to think that none of that is our
business anyway but when you start
trying to use a woman's husband's
infidelities against her to say that
she's unfit to serve because she kept
her marriage together and didn't leave I
don't know what their marriages I don't
know what their arrangement is and I
don't judge anybody in this life for
what system of love works for them
if they both have their own people on
the side they're staying together fine
it's so hard to make a relationship work
in this world so hard to make love work
in this world Hillary Clinton's been
married I believe a one-third the time
startled Trump has been married I don't
relationships or how they love right
it's all a sham marriage is fine it
works for them whatever I'm gonna go
based on the issues and not based on
someone's personal wise man Fugelsang I
got to tell you it is so refreshing to
talk to someone on the left with a
little nuance because this is what I've
been talking about for months that it
seems to me the left has lost their mind
everyone every time that you disagree
with sort of the mainstream progressives
you are a racist or you are a bigot or
you are a homophobe and they've made
good decent people that are basically
liberal or basically centrist or even a
little conservative they've made them
all look crazy and that is fueling Trump
so this is the exact conversation I've
wanted to have with someone that I
consider some
to cope one of the reasons why I've
never joined a political party because
people just lose their damn minds over
this and I look at Facebook or just just
become like it's become like like
electronic Bosnia everyone's war with
everyone I kind of feel like y'all are
gonna have to get along and share this
earth with each other after November of
this year and so I don't want to really
be a part of the hate or the rancor and
by that same token I'll defend Donald
Trump - I mean I'm I find myself
defending people I don't support who are
unfairly attacked more than anything and
it's it's really depressing but it kind
of shows how he got where we are by that
same token the very fact that Bernie
Sanders can go this far in a campaign I
mean he packed in 20,000 in a stadium in
in California in Sacramento last night
with 10,000 outside of course the media
didn't cover this but the very fact that
a a Jewish self-described Democratic
Socialist can do that well in this day
and age shows the power of the internet
and online social media and it shows how
far we come as a people I mean the
strides LGBT people have made in my
lifetime for when I was a teenager
living in New York in the 80s and seeing
the beginning of AIDS activism to a
sitting president endorsing marriage
equality during a heated reelection
battle that's why I still believe in the
American Dream because I've seen people
not politicians but people make this
kind of change happen yeah and you know
it's funny because right where you were
probably ten feet from you were when I
had my show on Sirius XM I think it was
the first time we had met or maybe we
did stand up one or two times together
but you came on my show and we were
talking about marriage equality and you
were laying out such a good case for it
but it was four years before it happened
and it seems sort of edgy where now it
seems the norm and that's what
liberalism is supposed to be sure I mean
look it was liberals in the Republican
Party who ended slavery right I mean it
was you know liberals from both parties
who fought for civil rights it was
conservatives of both parties who fought
against the civil rights movement you
know it's it's messy and like I said at
the beginning of this conversation I
think we're all progressive in some ways
and conservative in other ways that
least most sane people I know um so you
know I've seen a lot to be inspired by
in my life and I try to remind myself
that I am a recovering cynic and I don't
ever want to go back to
so dark again um and I'm catching a lot
of heat for it because you know in
talking about Donald Trump who is not a
conservative Republican he's just not
he's a horrible human being but if you
would ever told me Dave Rubin if you've
never told me that there would be a guy
on stage at a Republican presidential
debate saying that Bush lied us into war
saying the Planned Parenthood does a lot
of good things for for women saying that
that hedge fund managers and
billionaires like himself should be
taxed more I I wouldn't have believed it
I mean Grover Norquist is clutching his
pearls and a lot of this but again the
Third Reich did the same thing and I
think anyone who compares people the
Nazis is worse than Hitler
but I will say Third Reich rose to power
by by running against the by Mar
Republic and promising so many
conservatives and so many liberals
whatever they wanted that people just
kind of got caught up in the emotion of
it and this feeling of national pride
that's not to compare the Obama
administration's of Obama Republic
they're much more confident but the the
parallels are really really similar
because Donald Trump has promised as
much good progressive stuff as he's
promised conservative stuff